[Music]
I didn't go in there to villainize the
Democrats as a republican no it was not
that approach it's the approach that you
have to take and you ask about
leadership it needs the kind of
leadership that has the energy to not
worry so much about a specific policy
but to First bring the team together
this is what someone has to do in
Washington do those members rally them
together yes there will be different
ways of thinking in order stuff but you
got to Rally them together and say
Here's why
and make the case of where America needs
to go and what we need to accomplish
what makes this nation Great Is by
rebuilding it and fixing all those
problems that we have and the that that
you only can do with Democrats and
Republicans together we cannot do it
alone the only thing that sticks is if
Democrats and Republicans come together
and they meet in the middle and that
they answer to the people rather than
the special interest